[Musique]
subsistance
Clap clap
Non
[Musique]
sous réserve de la construction physique du nouveau capital en
Le Kalimantan oriental doit être rendu
élan pour construire une ville
une ville saine une ville efficace une
productif
conçu dès le départ et ses citoyens
partout à proximité
où peut aller Ma Hai en vélo
partout peut marcher parce que
Zéro émission
[Musique]
la nouvelle capitale nationale
pas seulement une ville remplie
bureaux du gouvernement
mais nous voulons construire un
charge de nouvelles Metropolis qui peut être
aimants pour devenir des aimants Global Talent
devenir un centre d'innovation
Salut
avec bien sûr on nous comprend maintenant
toujours dans une situation de pandémie et
nous sommes aussi en train de récupérer
l'économie ces deux choses seront toujours
majeur mais en cours de réalisation
en particulier la construction de la nouvelle capitale de l'État
car la quantité de mouvement initiale peut
classé comme un processus de
alors que la reprise économique est comme ça
[Musique]